we've been covering this story of Donald
Trump seemingly getting angry because
you didn't realize that he signed an
executive order which put all right
loving conservative ideologue and
political strategist Steve Bannon on to
the National Security Council we've
speculated is it because Trump didn't
read what he was signing is it because
he didn't understand it is it because
someone tricked him into signing it we
don't know but that aside what we can be
sure of is that Breitbart alt-right
propaganda Steve Bannon doesn't belong
on the National Security Council and
there was a epic confrontation on CNN
between this ex-navy seal Trump
supporter Karl Higby who's been
appearing on CNN for awhile during the
run-up to Donald Trump's election and
since he went on Kate Baldwin CNN show
and he said oh yes Steve Benin totally
qualified to be on the National Security
Council which is a stunning statement
and Anna Navarro who is also a
Republican strategist she destroys Carl
Higby and he actually looks like he took
a few punches in a boxing ring when
she's done with him again this is
Republican Anna Navarro who I don't
agree with her on a lot of positions but
with regard to being critical of Trump
when it's warranted she has been spot on
in many cases check this inter
Republican or would we call it in I
guess intra Republican battle on CNN
over Steve Bannon on the NSC now I got
it
Carl when it comes to a Security Council
are you comfortable with the president
signing on to something he didn't fully
understand what it meant well first off
I want to correct that statement I spoke
to somebody this morning who's very
close to Steve Danon within the
administration I said this is not
something that Donald Trump haphazardly
did on a whim he knew what was happening
what he was shocked about is the fact
that there's so much outrage but Steve
ban was a naval officer he was on a
submarine which means requires a
security clearance this is a guy who has
been successful at everything he's done
including in the military why is it such
a bad thing to put him on the national
security because he is a political
operative he looks at everything from
the political lens it is his job to get
Donald Trump reelected to keep Donald
Trump you know nobody honestly can be in
politics donors ever say that's why they
usually not either that's why the
political operatives in the form of
white roses
more vice-president well the college was
being provide president something very
different than actually getting the post
Anna Navarro is absolutely right she is
a Republican I am NOT singing her
praises on her political views but she
is someone that is at least more in the
sphere of rationality within the
Republican Party and she could not be
more right here Steve Bannon is a
political strategist the fact that he
was on a submarine as Carl Higby says
does not make him qualified to replace
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff in the Director of National
Intelligence as a regular committee
member of the National the National
Security Committee his job was to get
Trump elected right that was that was
Steve ban his job he is responsible for
the maintenance of Trump's image to the
public he can't even really do that well
as we've seen from the approval numbers
he is not someone who should be on the
NSC and Steve Bannon was in the Navy for
seven years but it's not like he was in
an admiral or something and was there
for his entire career it was just a
brief stint there are few things more
important to our national security
according to Republicans then who is
making the decisions about foreign
policy military etc so based on that
understanding how do you justify Steve
Bannon being involved in those decisions
even george w bush refused to let karl
rove be on the national security council
because he wanted to make it clear can't
believe I'm pointing to george w bush
here george w bush wanted to make it
clear that national security is separate
from politics and partisanship karl rove
was Bush's political consultant which is
what Steve Bannon is to Donald Trump and
when Trump put Bannen on the council
again he removed from the principal's
committee the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff as well as the Director
of National Intelligence this was
unprecedented shocking and illogical to
reasonable people
I thought Trump's populist campaign was
all about trusting government
transparency and not trusting the rather
all about not trusting the government
but about transparency what message is
sent when you remove people who are more
qualified for the
and put in a hyper partisan hack who's
out there to try to make you look good
and not doing a great job of it this is
a crystal-clear gesture that Trump is
not taking seriously the advice of the
military and intelligence community the
other thing I took issue with was Higby
saying that Michael Flynn was being
considered for vice-president yeah no
one's criticizing that you can have a
military person as vice president it's
just the other way around you can't have
a political operative in the National
Security counter which is yet again Carl
Haig be making no sense just really
seems general genuinely confused
whenever I see him on TV